everyone knows batman as one of the
flagship dc comics characters the dark
knight himself has consistently ranked
as one of the world's most popular
superheroes rivaling and often
completely outperforming most of the
major figures of the marvel cinematic
universe the hell are you supposed to be
as such bats often becomes part of a
much larger rivalry between two comic
book giants but it's worth noting that
this conflict exists more in the heads
of fans than it does behind the scenes
where actors creators and other talent
often feel free to hop between the dc
and marvel universes with ease for
instance the upcoming warner brothers
film the batman which reimagines the
gotham city legend in an even darker
light than before contains a number of
actors you will recognize in fact while
you might not realize it at first three
major actors from the marvel cinematic
universe will be shifting their gaze
over to dc in this film the first of
marvel's movie hopping mega stars
actually didn't appear until midway
through the infinity saga and that's
former golem actor andy serkis who is
the newest actor to portray bruce
wayne's butler alfred pennyworth in the
batman in the mcu circus's character is
a lot more villainous as he played
ulysses claw originally appearing in
avengers age of ultron before making his
way into black panther claw is the
underground arms dealer responsible for
stealing vibranium from wakanda while
initially framed as the primary
antagonist of black panther a plot twist
sees him murdered by his associate eric
killmonger who betrays claw as a means
of entering wakanda so that he may
challenge t'challa and overthrow his
rule the mcu isn't the only marvel movie
property that circus is tied to he was
also the director of venom let there be
carnage as such he is the only actor on
this list that has direct connections to
both dc and the mcu while also having a
role to play in sony's line of
spider-man adjacent films along with
circus irish actor barry kyogen also
appears in both the batman and the mcu
though his entry into the latter
occurred much later than that of circus
kyogen is in the batman as a character
who was kept secret officially billed in
pre-release materials as officer stanley
merkel the character he actually plays
in the movie is much more mysterious we
do know for certain that his mcu
character the eternal known as druid is
poised to continue appearing in future
films in eternals druid with his power
of mind control becomes one of the few
eternals to rebel against his celestial
creators though it remains to be seen
how he and his surviving family may be
punished for their rebellion finally
when it comes to joint actors shared
between the mcu and the batman there is
jeffrey wright who plays the famous
james gordon in the latter in most
batman stories james gordon is well
known as the gotham city police
commissioner and father of barbara
gordon aka batgirl he is one of batman's
closest and most trustworthy
collaborators and the main reason why
the gcpd is often depicted as having a
working relationship with the bat gordon
is an instantly recognizable role to be
sure most famously embodied in past
films by gary oldman in the dark knight
trilogy on the mcu side of things
however wright's role is deceptively
difficult to pick out if you don't pay
attention that's because unlike the
other actors listed wright's role in the
mcu is entirely done by voice and he so
far has not appeared in any movies this
mission requires a team the perfect
combination of skills and experience
instead wright's character of uatu aka
the watcher a cosmic being that observes
events across the multiverse only occurs
in the animated disney plus series what
if despite uatu's efforts to remain
impartial the series shows him
eventually realizing that a growing
threat requires his intervention with
the batman however we will finally see
wright in a mainline live-action comic
book film it's an exciting step to see
the actor take since wright has been
impressing critics since his breakout
role in basquiat back in 1996 also
starring another commissioner gordon
gary oldman
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you